Japan is crazy for fish each morning
thousands of merchants crowd Saku G
seafood market in Tokyo at Saku G no
product has a higher price than the one
that's the most taboo the puffer it's
the seafood version of Russian roulette
and extremely poisonous fish that the
Japanese call fugu despite the danger
fugu appears on more than 80 menus in
the Asakusa restaurant district so ugly
it's cute the puffer doesn't fool most
diners
Tom Cara Donna's in Tokyo for the full
fugu experience and he's brought his
friend Aki prudently tom has chosen to
eat at Matsumoto this 120 year old fugu
palace is known for careful preparation
important when you're dealing at the
toxin a thousand times stronger than
cyanide I've heard stories about people
dying trying the fugu
but it hasn't concerned me all the good
humor in the world can't bury the risk
over the years hundreds of people who
die from eating food chef Hayashi
has Tom's life in his hands it'll be
fine
don't worry I've been doing this for
fifty three layers or juha longer I took
the exam in 1949 and passed she finished
it
this is my fugu chef license after World
War two
fugu fatalities skyrocketed
starving Japanese woodcomb restaurant
trash bins
they'd salvage discarded fugu grill the
scraps and die
so General MacArthur who led the
American occupation force imposed strict
controls fugu chefs had to get licenses
even with stricter rules
death by fugu claimed 2,500 Japanese
between 1945 and 1975 regulation and
education have cut the death toll to
only three per year but dozens of diners
still get sick about 70% of the
poisonings happen in private homes where
people kitchen prepare food on their own
and get poisoned that's most common at
Tokyo University of Fisheries Nagashima
to G analyzes fugu poison he hopes to
develop an antitoxin for fugu a tiger
fugu has enough toxin to kill 30 people
the toxin itself to give you an idea as
1,000 times stronger than cyanide this
is one milligram of toxin enough to kill
you the neurotoxin kills by paralyzing
nerves victims can't move or breathe but
they are fully conscious until their
lungs fail the only way to save victims
to use a respirator to breathe for them
until the toxin wears off
this is the heart dogs you know these
are the gills don't they are poison
toxins taint about half the usual puffer
chefs throw those parts out then slice
the remaining flesh paper-thin arranging
it in the shape of a chrysanthemum the
national flower and appropriately enough
the choice for funerals in Japan
lucky Mouse
I can still breathe a typical kazoo meal
runs eight courses including sake with
dry roasted fugu Finn and I still feel
fine and grill fugu I think it's the
best a dinner that can kill you maybe
the ultimate food taboo but at least
this time around
Tom has triumphed over the puffer fish